einige Bundesländer planen jetzt ein
Führerschein für Hunde tolle Idee ich
sage aber lass uns ein Schritt
weitergehen was ist mit dem Führerschein
für Eltern und zu dem guten Führerschein
gehört natürlich ein guter
Bußgeldkatalog oh senen in English
please as long as you don't speak
English you want get Taschengeld sen
finger weg von der Schokolade J Banane
fruchtzucker ist auch Zucker guck mal
der Papa hat sich eine schöne neue Jacke
gekauft es passt zu deinem Fu Rucksack
ja werden die Jungs in der Schule aber
Augen machen hey kids ich habe einen Rap
gemacht in dem geht es um Recycling und
der geht voll ab hey NPCs welche Party
wird den heute Slayer Vlog oh se
gefangen war ein bisschen goofi von mir
sorry dafür so pass auf was macht ein
Security man in der Nudelfabrik er passt
da auf so ich wünsche dir einen ganz
schönen Sonntag hier ist s 1 bis 9 schon
vorgeladen das ist zum Fortnite zocken
und das hier ist das zweit Handy aber
nur für
tiktok du bist ein doof man das kann gar
nicht sein ich habe
Abitur selber doof Mann